right uh hey everyone welcome to the
second session actually this is the
wrong image
for the ml for audio study group i'm
omar from hoganface and we have a bb
here
hi bibi hello
awesome so today we have
two topics the first one will be a deep
dive into automatic speech recognition
and the other one will be an intro to
audio data before clicking the
presentations i would like to give a
brief reminder
of different organizational things
the first one is that we are using the
hook and face forum to ask questions
if you don't know where to get to here
you're probably watching in youtube
and here you can find the link to this
card to this course sorry
and also to the forum which is this link
ask your questions at discuss we also
have discord if you want to join the
discussion
to the channel ml for
audio study group
and finally we have everything in github
so here every week
we have this table which has which are
the topics we are covering
uh
where you can ask the questions which
resources you can read before
and we're also putting here the collapse
so for today which will be a bit more
practical towards the end we have two
collabs that you can try out and
yeah they are very nice
um
yeah going back to this uh
last time we said that next week we'll
talk about tts december 28th we decided
to move that to after the holidays
because i know that these
dates are a very complicated for many
people
so today will be about automatic speech
recognition coming back from new year
and we'll go to tts and then we start
with some more practical things
all right so i will be giving the intro
to all the data
pb will later give a deep dive into
automatic speech recognition and then at
the end we'll spend
15 to 20 minutes answering any questions
just as a reminder if you have any
questions
ideally please ask in
the forum
so
this is not a data like a signal
processing class or webinar there are
like very good materials out there if
you want to learn more about this
i'm happy to recommend resources to
learn more about it so this will be just
a very high level of of the topic it is
it won't be comprehensive it will just
be like 10 to 15 minutes
so the first question is what is sound
er so if you have a llama or if someone
is speaking next to you
how do you hear that
so pretty much when someone speaks or
when something happens uh
energy is getting displaced
so molecules in the air
are getting moved so there are
oscillations in the air
and this is pretty much what gets to
your ear and these differences in the
pressure due to the movement of their
molecules causes sound
and that sounds a bit uh
maybe a bit too theoretical but yeah
like just saying this picture
uh
you can see that there are like waves of
air molecules so this is like the
how if they are condensed or not
and you can see here that
in certain moments there are like many
molecules together and in some moments
it's more a sparse let's say
so of course this is only like one
single like a
sinusoid a like a sine wave
but of course when there are like
complex sounds it doesn't look like that
it's more something like this and this
is something that we call waveform so
waveform contains pretty much the
information of an audio it's a misc
like a mix of a difference you know uh
different sinusoids yeah
so there are like two
nice parts of it
one is the amplitude so there's like
high school kind of stuff but there's
like the altitude which is
the length from
the average in this case the average is
like the
atmosphere pressure let's say
to these points right to the peaks
and
the other is the frequency
so period is how long it takes from from
going from one peak to the next one
and the frequency is how many cycles is
the inverse of that so it's a how many
cycles per second of a wave right
so in this case the frequency
is very
very very small as you can see there
like
uh
20 something seconds or maybe more like
30 seconds for
a
going from that one peak to the next
peak but i think you get the idea
so normally a humans can hear
in certain ranges of frequency
and the metric the unit here is called
hertz right so humans can hear from 20
to 20 000 hertz but other animals such
as whales or dogs or bats they can hear
in different herds and if someone tells
you that certain noise
is at 500 hertz that means that there
are like 500 cycles in a single second
again here
pretty much try to understand like the
high level picture
of this like the high level concepts
don't try to focus too much on this
there are additional resources that will
be shared
later on to help you this
right
but one thing is that computers
obviously like this is continuous data
and computers do not read a continuous
data so we need to do things to convert
this to digital data that can be
processed by a ml a model for example
right event model cannot receive this as
input they need to receive something
like this
and so some usually there are like two
things that we do
the first one is something
something means that we are going to
sample at a regular point in time
so that means that every second you are
going to take 20 000
samples or 16 000 or 40 000 so it really
depends a bit
but usually 40 000 or
thousand
i recommend
and the second one is uh how much data
you gather for each sample
so
as you can see here a
a low sample rate means that you are
going to get very little data
let's say for one second and if you have
a high sample rate you are going to get
a lot of samples
but the next question is in terms of
amplitude so remember a horizontal axis
it would be like the frequency the
y-axis would be
like the amplitude
so how we can represent the amplitude
and i
i had this slight hidden but i think it
can be a bit useful to look at it and
pretty much the idea is that depending
on how many bits you want to have
for the amplitude you can have more
information so this is like the depth
so uh just to give you an example let's
say that you want to have a sample rate
of 40 000 so that means that every
second you are going to gather a 40 000
data points
and then
for each of those data points you are
going to have a 16 bits
so at this point you have forty thousand
bits
uh multiplied and sorry samples
multiplied times sixteen which is the
number of samples that you want we can
divide by one million to get the number
of megabits and then say so it's
megabytes
and let's multiply them 60 so it's for
one minute
and what this gives us is that for one
minute of data
we get
4.58 megabytes
so that's a lot of data actually and
that's only for one minute of audio and
that's one of the big challenges uh in
audio compared to other domains in which
the data is much smaller here we are
already talking about
four megabytes for one minute of audio
which is a bit white
so we talk about frequency we talk about
amplitude
one other important concept here is
intensity
so intensity is pretty much the rate at
which the energy is transferred
and you can see it as how
loud
the noise is so loudness is a bit
different because loudness is the
subjective perception so it's
how i as omar
perceive how strong that sound is and it
can vary
according to the age for example
but pretty much er that's the idea it's
measured in decibels
so frequency is in hertz intensity is in
decibels
and
it's yeah you can see here at the right
usually like humans perceive from zero
decibels to 100 decibels
and it's logarithmic so
going from zero decibels to 100 decibels
means a 10 million a
sorry 10 billion increase
10 billion range
so especially here at the top changes
here mean a huge huge difference
and
usually after 100
decibels it begins to be a bit painful
and there's a point in which your ears
won't work anymore
so it's not good to get there but
anyways let's return to some data
so usually as i was showing you before
there's like this
simple sinusoid but usually you get a
lot of data it's a misc of sinusoids so
this waveform
is actually a misc
uh let's say a combination you can see
like an addition of different uh
different sinusoids
uh
if using a in your life's
fourier transforms
it allows to decompose
um a set of waves that are combined
into each each of its individual
components so it's very useful to
decompose as a complex signal into many
of them
the issue with fourier transforms is
that they only work for a signal that is
not varying through time
in the case of audio of course it's
varying through time so you can use a
method which is called short time
fourier transforms which is this one
stft
which allows to decompose signals that
change through time
and it's pretty much just breaking the
audio into
many many small
shorter
chunks
and then it's applying fourier
transforms like the normal fourier
transforms to each of those pieces and
at the end what you get are
each of the different components and
it's super useful because then you can
get like the decomposition of the
complex signal
and this can usually be
plotted in something called the
spectrogram
so the spectrogram has three dimensions
let's say it's time frequency and
intensity so in the x axis you can see
how data
changes through time in the y-axis you
can see the hertz and then based on the
color you can see the intensity which is
here at the right
so that means that for a given
point in time when you're hearing
something you're actually getting data
in many different frequencies at the
same time and each of those frequencies
has a different intensity
so that means that the data is quite
complex so you get intensity and
frequency
every single
period in time so for every sample you
get
frequency and intensity
this might be a bit abstract if you've
never seen this before but i think it is
like a very important key concept to
understand
again if you have questions feel free to
ask them in the forum
we'll go back to them at the end
all right
so there's like one last change uh that
is important which is speech so actually
humans do not understand frequency
like in this linear scale that i'm
showing you here
they usually understand it much better
in logarithmic er
like logarithmic frequency
and the perception of frequencies
actually even a bit different and
there's a unit called mel so if you see
male spectrogram it's because of that
and pretty much male is the human
perception of frequency and this was a
scale that was proposed in the 40s and
there are like different proposals of
this this is subjective because this
depends uh on humans
but this is pretty much a table that has
been published
in different producing time
and it's there's like a formula to
convert from male to herbs and that
gives a
spectrogram which is
[Music]
which conveys more information
with respect to how humans perceive
something
so usually in traditional ml approaches
what people did when they had a
spectrogram was that they were computing
a bunch of or just audio
they were computing a bunch of manually
created features so empty to the
envelope band energy radio and other
stuff
and then they were feeding that those
features uh the traditional ml model
and the deep learning approach is a bit
different and the idea is let's just
give the spectrogram directly to the
model and that will be the input to the
model this might vary a bit and we'll
talk a bit more about this uh later on
right so that was the end of the audio
part
but before jumping into the next topic
i would like to very quickly show you a
a cool app
so again you can see the github repo in
the description of the video
there is this audio data a collab
notebook and you can click here opening
code and then you can execute directly
without needing to import anything
all right so
you can go through this codelab later
today that would be perfect or
whenever you want but it shows you how
to use libroza which is a very common
library for processing audio
and it shows you how to do a few things
so for example
[Music]
it allows to
plug
the wave the wave plot the waveform so
here you can see
uh what's the amplitude at different
time samples
you can look at the sample rate for this
audio which is 22 000
you can then see
how many samples you have you have so
you have 100 000 samples maybe let me
increase a bit the size of the screen
so for example if you have a sample rate
of 22 000 and if you have 108 000
samples
you can divide that and you can get how
long the value was which is 4.9 seconds
and then i showed you how to plot a
spectrogram
a using
short time
let me show you this one first there is
like a full description here so you can
use it so first i used a spectrogram
but this was not using logarithmic
so this second one actually is like a
normal spectrogram
using decibels and using log frequency
which conveys much more information so
the previous one
which didn't has a lot of information
but it's pretty much only at the bottom
you probably can't barely see it
and this second one
is much more informative
and then the third one will be the email
spectrogram which is the one that is
based on the human perception of sound
and finally like a super quick demo once
you have this audio
you can use libraries such as
transformers
which has a pipeline called automatic
speech recognition this will download a
model from the hub and we'll dive deeper
later today and in the next sessions on
these models
but just to have a quick idea of how you
can use this is you can load very easily
on audio
you can load a pipeline which will take
a bit the first time because it's
pulling a big model from
from github
and again this is only the first time
the second time you call this will be
much faster
and then you can just put here all of
the samples of data
you will get a
description of the text
of the audio
so this automatic speech recognition
with three lines of code
yeah and it's he began a confused
complaint against the wizard and
yeah if you trust me
that's what the audio is but i would
suggest you to go through this codec if
you want to understand a bit better how
all of this audio data works
having said that i think that's all from
my side eh i will answer some questions
about this at the end but i think most
of the questions right now in the forum
are related to automatic speech
recognition
so i think
a pp can
go next
all right perfect um let me just quickly
pull up my slides
sure i hope that's visible
perfect um so thank you so much omar for
you know walking us through um how to
sort of work around with audio data um i
think i specifically love like you know
um um sort of visualizing um the data
specifically like
um how um the overall um uh frequency
versus time graphs are we will see some
in a bit and you know you can you can
just understand so much more about um
about speed just through those so um i
think it's a it's a pretty nice exercise
to just look at some of your um speed
samples when you're dealing with them
um that's it so we're going to be
talking about for the next 20 minutes is
going to be automatic speech recognition
right um so we will basically be looking
at the task of transcribing audio um
and um
believe it or not it is actually much
more interesting than it just sounds um
so um
just a quick refresher uh what is asl so
asr
is you know taking some sort of an audio
and then transcribing it to ext
to text so what you see on the screen
right now is basically a waveform and we
we get it's time for lunch
from it right and
that's pretty much it
um
now now we have um like
in theory it sounds like a pretty pretty
easy job right it sounds like a pretty
easy task like you you have certain um
sort of frequencies for uh certain words
and or like certain phonemes and you can
you can basically um you know transcribe
them um
looks like it looks like a very simple
classification task but is it actually
um that easy
let's let's look at a couple of examples
so um if you look at the screen right
now there are three
sort of um
frequency time um graphs of three words
so this is wed
yell
and ben right and uh what i want you to
focus on specifically is the is the
variation of the phoneme
right so like what is the phoneme a
phoneme is like the
is like the most fundamental unit of um
sound that you can get to right so a is
like a
is like a phoneme and what you see over
here is in in different contexts um the
phoneme has a different frequency so if
you see in red it starts off with a low
frequency and sort of goes up
right in the case of yell it starts off
with high frequency and then goes down
right in the case of ben it is
sort of like
um sort of like a monotone so um
what we just saw is that
in three different words um just the
phoneme a had you know different
frequency patterns
um now just looking at our you know
previous knowledge of machine learning
um what machine learning does is it
looks for patterns
now if
um
if the word e-h oh sorry if the phoneme
e e has like different patterns then
that makes our job difficult or like
that that makes the machine learning
algorithms job difficult to actually um
understand um
whether or not it is um it is this
particular phoneme or not right so um
what this tells us is that um
the way um or like the way you would you
would look at um a particular phoneme or
the way you would um sort of
visualize the frequency time patterns of
of a particular phoneme can differ from
its context
case and point these three examples
um now let's look a little bit more in
detail
to um similar examples but with
different results so what you see on the
screen right now are four words um
which are way
re may and nay right
um in this scenario you will see that we
have different um
different context so
um
a has the concept of has the context of
w over here then in in this one has the
con context of um r in this one has the
context of m and this one has the
context of n
um however when you plot the frequency
time
graph of it all of them pretty much show
you the same thing
right so
what this tells us is that there can be
certain scenarios wherein a phoneme may
have the exact same behavior with
different context as well right so what
that what that means is that we need to
sort of
figure out some way to
um one understand like the local context
um and also the global context right so
um the way a phoneme is depends on on
both right um and there can be multiple
variations to it um and this is just the
example of english right when you go to
um you know more complicated languages
um like for example
if you look at german or if you look at
you know um sanskrit um or if you look
at hindi um many many such examples um
are there out there which have you know
where the
the sound of the phone name changes
considerably um as you
um as you you know change context from
from one to the other um so i just want
you to keep that in mind and this is
what sort of makes the entire process of
um creating an asr model um difficult
so um let's look at like how this was
done previously um so if you look on the
screen over here um previously you had
some sort of a speech you would take the
mfcc um which um omar
um showed us before
you take those features
and then you pass them through like a
multi-layer perceptron and
you sort of you know just just sort of
classify whether is this is this phoneme
or not is this phoneme you know um
or not and and so on and so forth so for
every 10 milliseconds you basically
um just
sort of classify which which sort of
phoneme is it right um and that's how
you train the model um
when it's inferring you will pretty much
add like some sort of an hmm on top of
these probabilities um which basically
gives you the the most likely path given
you know um seven eight phonemes or
three four phonemes whatever it may be
gives you the most likely um most likely
uh most probable
word off of it right or sequence of uh
phonemes off of it um so far so good but
um all of this still
assumes that um a lot of
phonemes are you know context
independent right so um if you if you
just take like one um slice of an audio
and you try to predict which sort of
phoneme is it without any prior or
um you know post um information to it
then that then that basically just um
just does not take any of the context
into account it just classifies that
particular slice of the audio file and
um that makes our model less accurate
so we'll see how we can sort of um
address some of these questions in a bit
um
so
keeping the keeping the historical sort
of aspect aside um let's look at some of
the
like some of the modern architecture of
asr i showed this last time as well
um and i think this this sort of this
image captures the the essence of um of
asr systems right so we have some form
of a waveform then there is like um
you know feature extraction which is
essentially mfcc
then there is you know some sort of sub
sampling then it goes into the encoder
and then you know you have the whole uh
decoding process essentially we treat
this as a sequence to sequence task
right so we input the the audio sequence
and we get the text sequence out right
and um
there is
you know of course there is like a
disparity between the um size of the
uh
of the input signal with the output
signal right um so
a typical example of this is like a
single word might just be like five
letters long so
hello um but it can in some cases take
up to two seconds right
um but the but the output is just
h-e-l-l-o
um so you know i can i can say something
like hello
um you know something like that when i i
extend the i extend the letter itself uh
sorry the word itself um and that is a
lot of input that is given to my uh
model
uh but the output is just five letters
right so how do we how do we sort of
make sure that um
that we're not sort of um we're not
putting in a lot of um
wait let me take a step back so how do
we how do we make sure that we're um
we're not overloading our model with
with like too much of information and
we're still like making sure that we
give the give the right amount of
information to our model right um how do
we how do we make sure of that um the
way we do that is through sub sampling
um as you see over here the most
simplest form of subsampling is um a low
frame rate wherein you
sort of concatenate the um the feature
vector of
you know f i so let's assume we talk
about um hello then we take the feature
vector of e um
uh the word uh the letter e and then we
sort of add the
um the one prior uh vector to it and the
one after vector to it so we create a
three x long vector um and then we feed
that into the
into the encoder so that way the
one the model has some sort of a history
plus like future
um value um sorry two historical uh
values um associated to it and um uh so
that that sort of gives it some sort of
a sense of like what the context is
and um uh we also like this way sort of
reduce
um
the the number of features we send to
the model right so we so so so we just
take
uh in this case we take say for example
um again let's take an example of like
within hello we take the feature vector
of l um then we take the feature vector
of e then we take the feature vector of
h
we concatenate them and we pass it to
the to the model right
um
similarly for the next l we take the
previous l and then the e and so on and
so forth right so the size of the vector
increases but then i don't have to
um
pass the same information again and
again right um we just we just
remove f i minus 1 and f i minus 2 and
we just continue
going
the same way so this way we can like
reduce um the input um at least by three
times
uh and and you know this sort of helps
decrease the parity between um the input
and the output
um so
so
let's let's do a quick recap so what
we've understood so far is that we use
some sort of um
sequence to sequence model um for you
know modern um automatic speech
recognition and um we we sort of input
the waveform and then we get the text
out right um
um and and so far we've sort of figured
out one sort of technique to reduce the
the input um so that
um
you know so that our overall sequential
sequence process is faster um
and like has more signal than noise
um but but like how exactly do we
know which part of x in the audio maps
to which part of the text right
so like how exactly do we know in this
particular case that this particular
waveform actually
actually belongs to i
like how do we make sure that this
belongs to d how do we make sure this
this belongs to um s you know and more
so how do we how do we make sure that if
like people have different ways of ways
of saying things right someone would be
like it's time someone would be slow
would be like eighth
time someone would be um someone would
just like be as fast as its time right
so how do we make sure that we we take
these variations into account and how
can we
how can we sort of model around it um
that's the that's the key question
that's left now
um the way we do that is through
the outputs a single character for every
frame of the input so for every 10
millisecond slice
it outputs one character right so this
way we like each input like each input
that we give to the model has some sort
of an output
attached to it right
so we get one value for each output and
then we apply like a collapsing function
which combines all the identical letters
together and we we get a shorter output
text sequence i know that was a lot to
understand so let's unpack this a little
um
what you see on the screen is like the x
input are the features from the waveform
right and for each and every
um
subsection
or of the waveform let's let's take x1
we have some output like so in this case
we have d
in the case of x2 we have i in the case
of x3 there is nothing but a blank right
so blank is also a
you know a valid
output so in case there was like you you
cannot classify anything
to it then you just say that this is
blank right the algorithm says this is
blank
then in the case of x4 and um and x5 um
both the the 10 millisecond
windows had the same
uh sound which is n um or
um and um so in both of them we have n n
right um then for xx we have a blank and
then for x7 we have um
n and then so on and so forth right
um and
then like once once we have like some
sort of a value for each and every input
uh then we just like merge duplicates
right so in this case if we merge
duplicates we have d i blank
both of these n sort of collapse into
one n then there is another break then
there is um another n and there is e
then there is like you know four r
r sort of collapsed into one r then
there is a break right in the next step
we remove the blanks
um and now we were just left with dinner
right so you can see like a 14
or like 140 um
millisecond
input which is you know if you assume 10
milliseconds per block um
collapsed uh into just five letters
right so um it's a pretty nifty thing um
and and it's it's still used like this
this algorithm is still used in in in
production
um out there there are of course
end-to-end esr models we will talk about
that in a bit but um
um
like ctc um in in general is used quite
quite often
in production
um
now one thing you would have noticed
over here is um
that
this also
allows us to have
multiple alignments um right for for
each transcription so now i have the
ability um to say dinner
with different um variations so i i can
say dinar
uh dinner or uh dinner
something like that right um
so basically with that different
different context as long as as long as
i don't go too
far off from the actual pronunciation um
i should be able to capture a lot of
variation
in the way someone pronounces a word
right and this is the beauty of it so so
we don't have to um like we don't have
to sort of come up with separate ways to
to understand um
uh different dialects of the same
language we can just use something like
this which which has a collapsing
collapsing function
um
um like in the case of ctc and and you
know we get the same transcription more
often than not um
and um yeah this is of course actually
quite fast as well because you're
essentially just getting one output for
each input and then you're just um
sort of
collapsing all of that and like getting
one
word of it
um so before i get to the
current state of the art um i just want
to take like a quick one um one minute
um about like two things which i'm not
covering over here because they um they
are like wee bit more
uh
you know complex for just a 15 20 minute
presentation um so one is ctc training
laws um which is like given ctc how do
we actually uh take the ctc loss
function into our overall sequence to
sequence model and how do we actually
you know um train the model um one and
the second is um given that we
we are employing the ctc function how
how do we actually infer right so um
if you if we go back to this slide you
would see that the training architecture
is a little bit different than the um
than the inference architecture so the
recognition over here is nothing but the
inference architecture right so um two
things that i have not covered is like
how do we actually um cover ctc laws um
while training um and and and the second
is how do we
um
use ctc while inferring both of these
are in 25.5 and 25.6 in the sorry 26.5
and 26.
um
six of um
speech and language processing book um
if you read it as a pre-read then you
would already know that if you haven't
then i would highly recommend you to go
through that um it would give you a lot
of insight into it and you know of
course if you have any questions on the
training laws as well as the
um the inference feel free to you know
just hit us up in the forums or on
discord and i will be able to help you
out um with that
um so quick recap up until now we we
understood what asr is we got a glimpse
of like how this was done beforehand um
then we got a glimpse of how it is done
right now um
you know in like a sequential sequence
approach we we looked at two key things
which is uh number one how do we sort of
um how do we make sure that um
we don't have too much input
given to the model and uh
you know with like very little output at
the end of it and the second thing is
like how do we make sure
that different variations in
them
um but there there are however um a lot
of um other
um state-of-the-art models some of which
are end-to-end like for example wave to
eck uh 2.0 is in is an end-to-end model
um it uses a convolutional transformer
which has like cnns um like so
transformer again is like a sequence to
sequence um model at the end of the day
and um
it it uses transformer in a in a
sequential sequence setting and then you
have like cnn blocks within it so cnns
are are typically very well suited for
this task because um they take they take
a window into consideration right so for
for for each window of the wave you sort
of get the local features
um from
that particular waveform and like
transformer in general are very good at
understanding the global context so you
get like both both the context quite
well um so we have to wait 2.0 is is um
or like some variation of favorite 2.0
is this is the current state of the art
um
in the speech um in the
domain of speech every three months you
will find like a new um you know a new
module which beats state of the art so
that's why i've written like current
state of the art this keeps changing but
you will see that it would it would at
the end of the day would be some variant
of the same
architecture right
um
then there is um
and the other thing which uh wave to
work uh vaporwave 2.0 does is that it
employs a pre-training mechanism
um which is similarly which is similar
to bird right so bird uses mass language
modeling and we have to wait 2.0 uses
masked audio
modeling so it would just um remove
certain chunks of um the spectrogram and
then it would let the model sort of
figure out what it is right um and that
that helps it understand um the overall
patterns of the of the speed signal
itself and so on and so forth um
then there is conformer conformer is
convolutional uh augmented transformer
um this again um has a similar
architecture to wave to way 2.0 uh minus
the pre-training um and and again this
this models both the local and the
global dependencies of the um of the
overall speed signal right um
then there is context net uh context nan
is
is a cnn rnn uh network this is i think
about two years old if i'm not wrong
um
uh this is not the the state-of-the-art
state of the art as such
but the reason why i uh put this over
here is because it uses like um squeeze
and excitation layers so essentially
like highway networks and you know
skip networks um within the within the
network to make sure that you have both
local and global context at the end of
the day um the the bottom line is for
for any of your waveforms you want to
make sure that your model captures both
the local features as well as has some
form of taking the overall global
features um
pulls those together and then you you
you go to the final uh
output textual output over there
um so um again i've linked all the
papers over here um we're more than
happy if you if you want to read the
papers and discuss the technicalities of
this paper again um the forums are a
good place for that discord is a very
good place for that um you can just read
the paper or like just read one section
at a time and if you have any questions
you can just post them and
um generally people in the community
respond quite quickly um so that's one
of the ways that you can utilize this
um
so uh
up until now we we sort of covered asr
at i would say like a five thousand feet
level right so not at a ten thousand
feet level but like we went a little bit
more deeper into it right and i think
that's about the right amount of
information that you need to start
playing around with with these models um
and you know start um sort of learning
on the side about them
um so let's
so let's go and look at the
the collab
for this so we created this this collab
specifically for speech recognition
tasks um
so there are plenty speech recognition
tasks right
um
just a quick thing before i get um get
going with this with this collab this
collab is in the ml with um audio repo
and um
i don't know if you can share the link
um on youtube or something but
you should be able to access it from the
repo itself as well
so let's quickly connect
um
this is a good time to look at the cats
on the collab
um
but
we will specifically be using a
combination of speech brain plus hugging
face for this so so speech brain if you
don't know it has a lot of pre-trained
models um available on the hugging face
um hub and you can you can directly just
pull models from there and use them for
your task um so that that that makes the
entire process of getting from an idea
to solution very very um easy for us
um before we get get our hands dirty
with the with the
with the code um
there are certain like tutorials from
speech brains that you can um that you
can
look at um so there is like a more
detailed speech recognition specific to
speech recognition um tutorial then
there's speech speaker recognition
there's thyrization
separation and so on and so forth so you
can like look these up in the
um
on on their documentation itself some of
this i will be covering right now as
well
um so you typically just need
you typically just need um
to have installed like speech brain and
transformers
um
which is not that big a deal and then
you can just input uh whatever it is
um just import all of these so we're
just importing speech brain and um
the read
audio function and um you can see the
beauty of um using like an like a very
simple encoder decoder esr system on um
um on a sample wav file um it's it's
literally as easy as just calling the
encoder decoder asr function as you can
see over here um literally just just
just calling that and then you can do
like from hyper parameters and you can
give like a source over here so this is
the
this is the name of the pre-trained
model and um you can actually just
go up to
um hugging face
models
and
over here
you can
you can either like directly just search
speech brain over here
and click over here
to find like all the models and these
are pretty much all the models that you
can that you can that you would want to
use right so if you look at um the first
one this is basically a speaker
verification model right
um
and
they have some details about it and they
also have you know how do you actually
get the embeddings and how do you
actually
perform speaker verification and so on
and so forth so i find this to be like
the best way to look at a model and like
um quickly open a collab and test out
whether or not it works um as well so i
just wanted to quickly give you a run
through of how you can you can use any
of the pre-trained models available by
speech brain um via hugging face hub
um
and uh in this particular case we will
takes about 10 seconds if i'm not wrong
for the first time and for the second
time as i mentioned it caches the model
so you won't have to download it again
um so while this while this runs we will
we will look at the output in a bit um
okay so these the output is here um
so we gave it this wave file um this is
present in the speech brains um
directory itself
um and
the the file itself is like the
transcription of the file is actually
the burj khano uh slid on the smooth
blanks and i know you can't hear my
uh hear the audio of my
collab but if you actually run this in
collab then then you would also be able
to hear that the the audio itself is
exactly the same as the transcription
right
um
and and i would just like give you um
give you the the opportunity later on um
just take your um
like take this collab search on on
hugging face hub for a different
pre-trained model and just like try it
out right there are there are encoder
only asr models there are encoder
decoder asl models in um supported by
speech brain just try this out so you
just have to pretty much put the name of
the pre-trained model and just see just
compare which model does well right and
you can also like replace the wave file
over here so you can upload
um
your own audio file and um just try with
that as well you know um i think it will
be quite fun
um
now last time someone mentioned uh how
can i separate uh different voices in
the
in the
uh
in an audio right and for that um speech
brain has like a pre-trained model
called sep former um it's basically a
transformer based separation uh model
which separates different um
audio forms
uh
within
a particular audio file and
i'm not gonna like play this out loud
but if you if you just
um run the code over here you can see
that um the first one is basically an
amalgamation of the two waveforms and
the second and the third one are um is
basically the separated um audio forms
um again i would say try it out um there
are other sep former models um creating
for longer duration for shorter duration
and so on and so forth um try them out
and
just compare them uh
with each other
and um
third of all um
we we can also verify whether a file is
from an individual or or not so for
example you can take my voice from this
video and you can take my voice from the
last video and you can compare if if i
am the same person or not right um and
for that there are um some speaker
recognition models which again speech
brain has and um you can just call those
and um you know
um
give like two wave wave files or
different files and and just see if if
they are the same or not in this case
they were not the same so the model
returned or false right
um
yeah
and uh
yeah so this was like a quick rundown of
like um of like how to leverage
pre-trained models there are some other
tasks that you can do so you can do like
spoken language understanding like you
can do some sort of classification you
could also do some sort of enhancement
which is if you have noise then you can
create a more um finer
audio
and so on but what if you want to train
an asr model on your own
data set then you can just um you can
run something like you can you can clone
the github repository you can run um an
experiment on um on their experiment
files you can just use them tweak around
with the hyper parameters um i'm not
doing this right now because we're
pressed with time where we're at 1750
but you can you can you can pretty much
just run these cells and um if you run
the
this particular cell it will train the
model on a on a very small data set so
it just takes 10
audio files and just trains the model
and you can you can effectively give it
like your own
data set and then like try running it on
your own and the reason why i chose the
cdc experiment is because this is what
we spoke about today so this is exactly
what
um we have um out there and um look at
the hyper parameters which is like how
many layers are they putting and like um
what kind of dropout do they have what
kind of um learning rate do they have
and so on and so forth and um
yeah and then like um you take the
um you take the same sample data and i i
recommend you train a sequester sequence
um model for it uh and you know if you
want to
sort of
figure out how to do that uh look at the
integrations folder linked over here
right um i would be really interested to
know what you what you build out of it
or like if you just try something um
you know feel free to uh write to us on
discord um as to how you use those or if
again if you face issues um just write
to us
on discord
um
so i'm gonna
i'm not gonna take a quick pause um
and get back to the slides and
um that was the as our bit
awesome hey thanks a lot
so i think we have a couple of minutes
for questions
just before going to the questions
two quick things
as i mentioned at the beginning a
next session won't be next week but
next year
there will be like two short
presentations one from vp about uh tts
and the second one is actually open at
the moment uh so if you have any ideas
or anything you would like to learn
about feel free to suggest us in
in discord if you would like to
volunteer as a speaker if you would like
to present about something related to
automatic speech recognition or tts you
can go to to the repa
and you can open an issue here
for example there's already this one
which is music generation and processing
so if you would like to talk about that
you can uh suggest
yourself but you can also just open a
new issue
and here you will be able to put a
proposal for a quick practical workshop
that you could give
sorry for that
all right
and
yeah so recommended resources for next
time is going through the two notebooks
that we showed today and also reading
chapter 26.6 uh
26.6 which is about dts in particular
let me close that one
all right
and one last thing before going to the
questions
are you sorry for that
is that in cognitive phase if you go to
models uh there are like two things you
can do so if you want to filter for a
library so
like bibi was doing few minutes ago you
can click
here
for a speech frame and then you can find
like all of the speech french related
models uh there are other libraries for
audio transformers also has audio
support as i was showing before there's
also asteroids for example
and if you're interested in a particular
task you can click the plus 12 here and
there you can see all of the audio
related tasks
so text to speech
audit audio of the classification esr
so something like some people might be
interested
if they want to search for
a pre-trained models
or models to use for something
let's try to be super quick with
questions because we don't have that
much time
let me criticize yeah so the first
question is
what are suitable approaches for dealing
with data sparsity such as a limited
audio data in a specific language
and the second part is if we could uh
create synthetic data via tts
and
so there are like two things you can do
and maybe if you've done computer vision
or nlp
it's kind of similar
so the first one is that you can already
pick a pre-trained model
so normally like these pre-trained
models in nlp for example already have
like a
statistical understanding of the
language in which it was trained and you
can then fine-tune it for your
particular task so we previously
mentioned wave 2 by 2 so you can take
waves to vector and then find you need
for your own particular task
the second thing is that if you don't
have that much data very similar to
computer vision you can do data
augmentation so you can add a noise for
example like background noise you can
just change the waveform to make the
audio faster and they're like
some nicer approaches
i'll share this later in the forum but
there's like this paper from google from
two years ago which is called a speak
augment which is to augment a speech
data which might be interesting
and
i was not sure about this tds approach
so i just undone from the team
so this would be similar uh this is a
bit of an unexplored
area
so for example in computer vision there
are people that are exploring in using
guns
to create synthetic data sets and so
it's kind of similar in that sense but
it's a bit unexplored research area
there might be some papers on this but
usually people don't do this
yeah let's go to the next one from
alexei
what's the current approach to dealing
with different dialects of the same
language
right so
yeah
like specifically for this so one of the
one of the approaches that um that we
covered in the asr slides which was ctc
is um is is actually quite
good at doing this right so um typically
in dialects what would changes is the
way that you um that you enunciate or
like the way that would that that you
would pronounce um
a particular word right and um
there can be like different um
outputs to an input over there but as
long as they all collapse down to the
same letter uh it is fine right um
another thing uh is like now with the
with the with the end-to-end models and
and especially with like a lot of um
pre-trained uh models so like we have to
wick uh 2.0 is a very good example of
that and um just just by the masked
audio modeling that it
implies the model itself learns the um
the subtle like features between
um
um between um
you know the audio signal itself right
so um
when you have a model which which
consumes that much data and like um
learns to sort of effectively denoise
the noise or you know learns to predict
what would come in in place of a blank
um
um the model
sort of understands um this whole thing
um
yeah there is there is like one more
point um to it but i'm not gonna give
that out um say that out loud you can
handle this with like hmms as well uh as
in the previous um
um
previous models are like the um the
age-old models but when i respond to all
of these questions in the in the forums
then i would put the link to
to all that i'm saying and uh give you
um an explanation of that as well
some thanks
er let's go for the next question so
this question was mostly about how to uh
run some of this solve some of these
tasks through inference in in the phone
so in android for example
uh
right
um so i'm gonna take a quick pass at it
i i i am not an expert at ddsd um first
of all let me let me say that uh i
impact today was the first day that i uh
like was the first time that i actually
looked at it um but from the looks of it
uh ddsb is is nothing but an auto
encoder model right um it takes it's
it's still at at its core is the
sequence to sequence task right so you
you have an input sequence and you and
you're given given um output sequence to
it right um uh so
as goes with with with with any sort of
network uh or any sort of deep learning
network you if you want to use them um
at an edge case uh or like for an for an
edge scenario you either you know expose
an api for it and then you provided some
sort of an input and you get the output
for it or you you know convert it using
tf light um in the case of um
uh what's called android in the case of
android you convert it using dflight and
you know create a smaller model and then
like embed it right um so it's
effectively similar to how you would do
for any deep learning model so and and
ddsb is no um
um is no
uh exception to that um to your question
about what is the most like if there are
any best android projects to implement
speech recognition i'm afraid i don't
know of any um
except say google um assistant i don't
know if they have their
uh models uh available in public but um
that's the one which i know but i i did
see that the magneto team um which also
introduced ddsp um has a couple of
models out there which you can you know
convert using df light and then
test them out in the wild
cool thanks
maybe you have like five more minutes uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay awesome
we're almost done with questions so i
think it's nice
if we finish them so this question from
coppocho is why haven't we moved away
from the men's scale
so it was done in the 1940s to
here's original paper
with only five participants participants
uh
so yeah there are actually like
different
log equations as you're mentioning here
we were talking with 3b before this is
like kind of something that people don't
think much about i think there are like
different main skills as i was
mentioning before so if you search for
it you can find many scales and
a male scale in the 90s a masculine in
the 40s so there's like a very a
subjective thing there's something that
if you change the participants you can
get different results so it's not fully
replicable and it's like very easy to
even introduce biases due to the people
that are participating on this
i don't know if there's any better
approach maybe people can comment in
discord if they have like some nice
ideas
or if they know some papers that are
achieving better results of this
right i i just want to like quickly
comment one thing on it right so like um
there's an entire process that that that
goes through right so we
like there is male scale there are
filter bla banks there is like
quantization there's like a lot of steps
that happen right um and like um
the main reason why this happens or like
the main reason why we do is to extract
the most most important features um from
an audio signal uh the one that are most
distinguishing
um
you know um off that particular audio
signal so um it may not make sense to
just like look at one individual siloed
element of it but if you look at the
entire
um entire pipeline of extracting
features um right from the audio signal
all the way till you know um
getting the mfcc then i think it would
it would make much more sense um for
that i would i would recommend reading
26.2
uh from slp and they sort of walk you
through the entire process of like
windowing uh then like you know what
kind of windows can be there there can
be hamming windows so on and so forth
there can be filter banks and and like
so on and so forth um and like when you
look at that um
from like one end to the other um
including like four year transform and
so on and so forth then it all starts to
make sense um that said it's a very
valid question um uh i have never um
i i never thought of this and even when
i took the class at the uni uh
no one ever brought that up
so this would make for a very good
discussion
yeah yeah for sure it's a very good
question
[Music]
from jonathan is a will you make a
tutorial on audio so i can generate a
certain person's voice
or replace my voice and change it to a
uh
i don't think we have this in the
like we have topics for the next two
three sessions but after that it's
pretty much open-ended to whatever the
community wants
uh so as we were talking before you can
propose topics uh via
ethical issues or in the discord and
maybe like people want to brainstorm and
propose attack
but it's very open open ended for for
the future
yeah just just one quick uh point on
that um specifically for this you might
want to check out uh ddsp from uh
magneto team um which you were just
talking about before they actually um uh
create um
or sort of provide like a sequential
sequence set up where and you can you
can actually do that and they have some
pre-trained models that you can um
leverage
um i have not um used them personally
but um if you decide to go down that
rabbit hole feel free to holler at and
um you know we can
make a
make something together for sure
awesome and
last question is
just chris to notice is it possible to
identify someone's voice
and replicate it in further producing
content
so in terms of identification um i'm
not sure if you followed the the collab
notebook that i was um
going through there is a there is this
thing called speaker sort of
verification wherein like you try to
verify whether this particular audio
belongs to the same person or not right
um
so you can you can definitely use that
sort of a setup to identify um a
particular person and then you can use
something like um again as we mentioned
about ddsp to uh to then like replicate
um their way of speaking with that um
i don't have anything for the for the
second bit but um when i respond to this
question in the forums i would
definitely
um look for
um some sort of repo which does that so
um don't worry about it i will send you
some sort of a link for it
awesome
there were a bunch of questions in
youtube at the end
i think we'll skip those because we're
already way over time we'll put this
in the forum as well and we'll also
reply there later on uh today or
tomorrow tomorrow probably
but yeah thank you very much everyone
for joining thanks vb for the great
presentation
please check out the collabs they are
really worth checking out
especially the speech frame one is fun
you can
play out with different models
and even then you can go on the hub and
you can just search for
automatic speech recognition model
uh
this is from transformers you can just
click here using transformers and you
can try out the models directly you can
play them direct with them directly in
the browser but yeah try to use the
codelab from bb
to get a better understanding on using
existing pre-trained models
and then how to train a model for your
own task
or with your own data sorry
but yeah thank you everyone have very
happy holidays a happy new year for
people that are celebrating new year in
these stages uh yeah thanks a lot
yeah just just one quick thing i i know
that there were like questions in the in
the youtube if you want you can send
your questions on the forums as well
just just like if if we haven't answered
those just um you know reply on the
forums and um you know we will sort of
respond to all of them in one go maybe
probably by tomorrow morning um so you
have time to put in your questions if
you if if anyone has more questions the
more the merrier um i typically like the
questions part the most about these
sessions
so send them
yeah yeah just feel free to join to join
discord and ask more questions like
unrelated to this talk and share
resources that you've been looking at
for ideas
yeah
looking forward to it
thanks a lot
alright bye